our senior news editor Jennifer perros
and Jen you got things cooking with
ninety sort throught Freddie Prinze jr.
huh oh I did Nancy well we all know
Freddie from the fun teen romance movies
like she's all that and I know what you
did last summer his father
Freddie Prinze was the legendary
comedian from Chico and the man but what
most people don't know is how close his
father was to the late Muhammad Ali as a
kid growing up in Spanish Harlem
I used to watch Muhammad Ali on TV all
the time my dad and Ali were great
friends and he used to go to Ali's house
a lot and my dad's fooling around with
Ali one day and he cracks Ali in the
nose with a left hook and I'll he falls
on his couch and he gets a bloody nose
my dad runs to the bathroom he gets
Italia wipe the blood off Ali's face
brought the towel back framed it and it
was close to his birthday think it says
June 19th 1975 Ali's blood and its frame
like you thought he won like a war medal
Freddie's father only lived to the age
of 22 he was less than a year old when
he died he's a hands-on dad himself now
with two kids with wife sarah michelle
gellar and turns out he's quite the
amateur chef so your wife is she a big
fan of her cooking yeah that's why she
married me it wasn't for any other
reason that cook probably four nights a
week
Sarah co-starred with Robin Williams and
the crazy ones and Freddie and Robin
ended up friends Robin Williams and you
became close and you guys have plan on
doing a dual Thanksgiving family dinner
together we always talked about having
this dinner and and the types of foods
that he liked and the types of foods
that I love to create when I go on next
week yeah next week yeah next week and
then one day he was just gone and we
never got to have that meal Freddie's
new cookbook back to the kitchen
features family friendly recipes married
for 13 years he has a bone to pick with
Howard Stern because of this you're
gonna cheat um ah ah you are I'm not
you're gonna end in divorce no I'm not
bet me a million dollar Sarah and I
would divorce and breakup in five years
so you owe me a million bucks bro yeah
Howard does need to pay up 1 million
dollars Freddy and Sarah Michelle Gellar
are approaching her 14th year wedding
anniversary this September